welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the predictor
that definitely couldn't have predicted
the ending of this episode because damn
so there's a lot to talk about in this
drama heavy episode of agents and
throughout this video we'll be going
over our theories predictions and
discussing the things you might have
missed obviously there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't anything
ruined then I highly recommend that you
turn off now
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy the
video and make sure you subscribe to the
channel for breakdowns on the show week
by week without further ado thank you
for clicking this and let's get into our
breakdown of episode 6 ok so we open
with the chronicles leader the predictor
looking over the timestream the
chronicles are sick of taking ELLs and
the predictor or Sibyl discusses how the
timeline always adjusts to create new
and branching paths so though the agents
may have beaten them at every single
turn that doesn't mean that there are
new opportunities for them to change
things they do this by ominously
activating all the other hunters that
they have in their arsenal and they send
them after shield in a very very nice
twist now at the Lighthouse
main Coulson have been captured and they
taken to Ric stoner who yeah I can't not
hear Gio from Family Guy when he talks
now whilst the Zephyr has the ability to
cloak it turns out that stoner can track
them due to an advanced system that was
gifted to him by Malick this was
obviously given to him by the chronic
comms and I love how they're pretty much
equipping the past with the weapons in
tech that they need to fight the agents
in advance onboard the Zephyr Mac is
angered by deke killing Malick and to
make matters worse Daisy and Sousa are
missing and his parents are still in a
Cell at the Lighthouse now last week we
said that the chronic comms purposely
chose his parents out of everyone
because he would definitely save them
over the mission and from the prologue I
think they also knew that he would
immediately try and rescue them which is
what the predictor was talking about in
regards to new opportunities Malik had
nothing but happy memories over the
Bicentennial in the original timeline
and shows that the villains know the
agents really well I think
the predictor might link back to them in
some way and she just seems like such a
weird character that wouldn't be
surprised if she was related to somebody
on board the Zephyr actually thought
that for just a split second that she
might be Mac and yoyos kid but we'll
wait a while before discussing that
theory so I don't look even more stupid
than I do now
speaking of Mac Henry Simmons who plays
the character turned 50 yesterday Wow
and yet looking good looking very good
mate now other birthdays include Daisy
Johnson who in the show turns 32 on the
2nd of July so lots of things to
celebrate besides the Bicentennial and
happy birthday Henry and Daisy and Oh
Daisy's not a real person now Mac and
yo-yo head out to bring the pain to them
for once the lighthouse is put into
lockdown
due to the chronic calms AI they lock
onto the Zephyr and fire missiles at it
which lead to the action scene that we
saw in the trailer last week though the
agents prepare themselves for extrude
juice they're still hit and this damages
the Zephyr to the point that if they
jump again they'll be torn apart I'll
talk about this later in the video but
it does give us some clues as to what's
going on with Simmons elsewhere Daisy
and Sousa have been tied up and she's
unable to use her powers due to being
drugged Nathaniel shows up and though it
seems like he's part of Hydra initially
he's actually working outside of them
his goals are very simple and all he
wants to do is transfer Daisy's powers
into him and Daniel's which he believes
is slower aging but as we know he's just
been time traveling now using Daniel
Whitehall's theories he's come up with a
method to do this and if you've not seen
the other series then here's a quick
catch up on who Daniel is the second
world war he worked on the Red Skull for
Hydra and was captured in 1945 the
character experimented on Inhumans and
because of his work on one core GA Yin
aka Daisy's mother he was able to da Jim
self in the original timeline he was
freed in 1989 by Hydra and became a
villain in the show now back at the
lighthouses stoner starts to interrogate
Coulson in May who try and tell him
about the Chronicles but it falls on
deaf ears however made you - her empathy
abilities picks up that something is
not right with one of the agents that
comes to visit them and thus they
conclude that she's a chronic calm we
discovered that this was her first
assignment and we learn that the chronic
comms Scimitar Coulson have found a way
to upload human personalities into
synthetic bodies and thus they can
control people I love how there's this
sort of invasion of the body snatchers
vibe to this episode with the chronic
comms slowly replacing all of shield
with their own one by one on board the
Zephyr Simmons tries to fix the control
panel but you can't remember how to do
it now we learned that Simmons actually
has a memory suppressant and a spine
called Diane that will hide where Fitz
really is
we learned that Fitz is monitoring
everything about the chronic comms in a
location that allows him to see all that
they can do and Gemma knows that he's
there but they've hidden this from her
just in case she's caught now sometimes
when I make a video and put alive I
immediately start coming up with things
that I should have said in it and within
the first five minutes of uploading the
last breakdown I started theorizing
instantly and I've waited for a week to
talk about my new theory that is that we
still don't know this truth about Jemma
so we do know that Jemma and Fitz spent
a long long long time working together
on the Zephyr and Coulson and yet they
don't seem to have aged actually think
that Jemma is incredibly old and that
she has in fact gained dementia and this
is why she's forgetting things
she says that Enoch was fixing her
memory and thus I think this implant is
to actually help her remember things
rather than to make her forget them as
for Fitz because he's not onboard the
zephyr he's likely taking the long way
around and going through all of the
decades in normal time thus I do think
that when we come face-to-face with him
he will be extremely old that's just my
theory for the moment and it would
explain how Jemma isn't really aging and
I think the implant is doing a lot to
her
maybe Diane stands for dementia implant
and neurotic engineer Ora
you know they love their anagrams but I
do think that we still haven't uncovered
the full truth with her obviously let me
know your thoughts below but that's the
theory that I'm leaning towards this
week at the Lighthouse Mac and yoyo
break into the former's parent cell and
Mac hugs his mother which his dad
hilariously stops him from doing Mac or
more introduces yo-yo as his girlfriend
and it's a hilarious scene even if it
does kind of leave things pretty messed
up by the end of the episode he and his
father end up working together because
of a lock being similar to a car and as
we know Mac worked on vehicles a lot
with his brother when he was growing up
maeín Coulson gets a STONER and there's
a nice little line where the chronic
calms talked about removing his face
after Stone a request set to be taken
off the AI now we did say that we
thought Donna would create the message
that would appear in the lighthouse in
the future as people have had questions
over this for a while and how exactly he
knew what was going on when the message
was recorded in the past it looks like
all that he was was the face of the AI
and this was adapted to the agents
arrive in there and it created the
message so now unfortunately we don't
get a cool moment where they tell him
about the future a STONER believes them
after seeing things firsthand and
Coulson descends into the basement where
he comes face-to-face with a predictor a
Nathaniel's born he begins to take blood
from Daisy and this leaves her at
death's door Sousa really cares for her
on comforter she hangs in there and I'm
telling you I'm shipping Sousa and Skye
right now I really want the guy to get
some happiness and I do think that they
left him single for a reason
Daisy is single too and maybe he had to
get out of time to be with the one that
he loved just like how Steve did he
talks about his time on the front line
and realizes that Daisy managed to hide
her metal-shod in the hand which yeah I
wasn't expecting it to be that graphic
Suzy uses this to stab one of
Nathaniel's henchmen and Malik shows up
with his newly acquired quake powers
however he's unable to fully control
them and Sousa and Daisy managed to get
away
Coulson meets with the predictor through
their synthetic digital world and she
explains how she doesn't actually see
the future she just sees the past and
this is how she's able to adjust and
change things so well they want
earth to ensure the survival of their
species and the reason that they've
chosen the planet is because due to time
humans act irrationally whilst alive as
chronicles do not face time they act
much better than we do however they're
not willing to also do the more positive
things that humans do such as making
sacrifices and never giving up Collison
also says that dying is a superpower
before exiting the VR simulation and
destroying all of the new hunters that
were replacing the shield agents Coulson
dies again but I mean the guy he pretty
much says that he can't die like he
actually says that so yeah he's coming
back it'll probably be another time jump
but I bet that Simmons has a copy of him
so yeah I'm not too worried stone ax
tries to chat me up who shuts him down
with the level seven body slam and she
shakes his hand probably feeling the
raging hard a love that he has for heard
as Mac & Co X at the base may senses
that Mac's father is a chronic calm and
to make matters worse his mother is too
it's a completely crazy twist but since
taking their personalities and makes
sense that they were able to fool
everyone so much it turns out that
they'd abducted Mac's parents for a
while and hearing his dad say that he
harvested his father's skin it's really
messed up Mac manages to kill his robot
parents and what this does to the
timestream we don't know yet but clearly
Mac's life will be very very different
the border Zephyr everyone heals up
including Daisy who's put into a chamber
Sousa decides to say with that I'm
telling you they're gonna be together
the group jumped to an uncertain future
and Mac rides out on a motorbike to go
and get some air deke goes out to check
on him and we get another huge twist
which is that the Zephyr time jumps
again leaving them stuck in whatever
decade this is hikes
now we will be talking about the trailer
for next week so have you done anything
wound then I recommend that you turn off
now I have had comments in the past
saying not to just jump into it so yeah
this is your time to jump out now it's
gonna be set in 1982 and we'll focus on
deacon mac returning to the lighthouse
and partying it up we also see that
Coulson left them a message which means
that he is indeed alive we just don't
know where my guess is that he shows up
at the end of the episode and it looks
like the chronic comms have infiltrated
the tech at the base and have made the
rocky for looking robot turn into the
Terminator either way there's a lot to
look forward to and the show just keeps
getting better and better in my opinion
now obviously I'd loved hear your
thoughts on the fifth episode - make
sure you comment below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and if you missed our
analysis of any of the other episodes
then make sure you check them out after
this I'm going to support the channel
from his letters 99 cents a month then
please click the join button below
we massively appreciate it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you're gonna catch us after the
show either follow us at heavy spoilers
you'll click the discord link in the
description below every month we give
away free movies to people are
subscribed to the channel and this Monty
come on the MCU infinity saga box set
and all you have to do is comment on a
video and make sure you subscribe with
notifications on the winners gonna be
chosen at random on the 15th of July and
this that'll be shipped out from the end
to ever gets the price so best of luck
to everyone who takes part Cheers
you